so this past september a dream was
realized when the academy museum of
motion pictures opened its doors a
museum like this comes with a hefty
price tag
482 million dollars and i know many
people in this room donated generously i
did my part and this weekend
this past weekend i paid a visit to see
where my 15 went
barbra streisand bridge i wonder how
much she donated to get this
i knew i shouldn't want to be 25 bucks
excuse me can i help you yeah i'm here
to see my stuff oh the ticket booth is
right over here i on the sikes i'm a
donor what level
15 big ones 15 000
oh miss sikes that's tax deductible
right
i know some of these people that's our
donor wall
okay come on in uh go ahead i'll catch
up with you
this is one of our most popular exhibits
oh you ain't got to tell me what this is
billy porter kinky boots originally it
was called kiki kitten heels
with the rookie slippers
tom you got this whole room for the
wizard of oz and this is the only thing
you got from the wiz
i got this
you ever been to meryl streep's house
looks just like this
this is a very important display haddad
mcdaniel was the first black oscar
winner her award went missing after she
donated it to a university devry
and this empty case honors her historic
win
[Music]
it also honors all the oscars won by
black directors
i'm sure you will recognize this famous
oscar gown worn by little richard cher
in 1986
when she presented at the oscars but
didn't receive a nomination i see
this is what you wear when you break up
with oscar this is like the ultimate
revenge gown because it says you could
have had this you could have had all
this
everything in this room belongs to mr
spike lee
woman he just left it here
how about y'all charging him for storage
the academy isn't charging mr lee
anything
he stores it here for free okay i got to
get in on this cause i'm paying 250 out
of glendale
is it 24-hour access
oh
white chicks that marlon wayans was
hilarious
this is from aquaman jason mamoa no this
is guillermo del toro's creature from
the shape of water
well you didn't see jason momoa after
filming all day underwater
[Music]
hey harvey weinstein
here we have film history with over 700
films from the lumiere brothers to
present day you know they have monitors
like this at best buy you pick the one
you want and they load it right into
your car
i'm gonna take this one come grab it in
no no
no miss sykes